-You love taking
your little ones
to the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade.
-Pick me up, pick me up!
-And they love watching
the parade from your shoulders.
But we all know what happens
when they're up there
for a three-hour parade.
-Daddy, I have to go
to the bathroom.
-We're kind of stuck,
can you hold it, pal?
-Accidents happen.
-Ugh, come on, kid.
-So for this year's parade,
Patagonia and Pampers
teamed up to create the all-new
Peetagonia.
The first jacket
with a built-in neck diaper
to keep you dry
when the kid on your shoulders
treats you like a human urinal.
-Daddy, I have to go
to the bathroom.
-Go right ahead.
I'm wearing my Peetagonia.
♪ Let it flow, let it flow,
let it flow ♪
-You'll stay completely dry.
-And warm, too.
-Oh, hell no.
Come -- Come on.
-Peetagonia --
Let it rain on your parade!